laissez-moi terminer avec cela le renfort
se rétractera à 45 degrés de la
fusée
cinq quatre trois deux
un zéro
et la résilience augmente même pas la gravité
contient l'humanité lorsque nous explorons
comme un pour tous
et nous passerons par max q
ici sous peu la plus grande structure  charger
pendant l'ascension maxq falcon 9 a
regardé le lancement était magnifique je
n'ai pas de détails sur les
anomalies que nous avons eues, ce qui est génial
euh nous obtiendrons plus de données au fur et à mesure que nous avancerons, le dragon a
été déposé
environ 12 minutes après le début de la mission dans
une belle  orbite
et elle fonctionne très bien tous les
systèmes nominaux ont
exécuté une brûlure et je pense qu'il en reste
deux à faire,
nous approchons de la station spatiale dans un
peu plus de 24 heures à partir de maintenant
, puis nous pourrons pousser un soupir
de soulagement
euh 26 environ  dans quelques heures, une fois que nous remettrons
l'équipage
à la nasa dans les 15 prochains mois, nous devrions
effectuer environ sept
missions de dragon et cette mission
représente l'
initiation d'un dragon en orbite
qui
frappe continuellement  sur le bois et c'est
certainement le début d'une nouvelle ère dans
le vol spatial habité
alors merci beaucoup à
vous